ready for a night at the Museum of
Tolerance a palcohol
I am Oh Gillian turn that song up no no
he's my baby blue she's wet yeah oh cool
you see everyone's technique chilly a
great idea for a party you brought your
scalp collection no no Blake they're my
costumes I'm taking an improv class I
thought this would be the perfect place
to start auditioning some of my
characters I should be an actor a lot of
people say I look like Matt Damon
it's ugly younger brother Philip just
more jowls I wouldn't say that a lot of
people don't know about him people say I
look like we're down sometime yeah I
guess son
oh wait answer that's a beard oh oh hey
buddy are you looking for mr. Walker's
pool party yeah that's right it's gonna
be next door in our community pool
really interesting he's a trickster okay
is it trickster you guys need you behave
yourselves for real good I'll throw this
one away right now yeah thank you
rocking jog ten point shot get it hello
oh I am sorry about this dan Cortese
would have made that you would have made
that he honks wear shoes
you